the late Henry Kissinger is being widely
remembered as a giant of global
diplomacy but in Latin America many are
applauding the death of a man who helped
orchestrate military coups throughout
the region in the name of US National
Security perhaps nowhere is Kissinger
remembered less kindly than in Chile
seen here shaking hands with dictator
austo Pino in
1976 Chile's ambassador to Washington
says quote he was a man whose historic
shine couldn't hide his profound moral
poverty Declassified US Government
documents and audio tapes reveal how
Kissinger backed Operation Condor a
campaign to hunt down and assassinate
leftwing opponents of South America's
dictatorships especially in Chile
Argentina and Brazil odet man's sister
Cecilia was arrested and disappeared
under Operation Condor she was 27 at the
time odet says Kissinger died with blood
on his hands this is a man that won the
Nobel Peace Prize
please it he he did nothing of the sort
and and the irony of this is a man that
died when he was 100 years old and is
responsible for deaths of thousands of
young people that were in their 20s the
bodies of countless opponents of Chile's
military coup once floated down the
mapocho river that runs through Santiago
many historians politicians and
relatives of the victims of the military
dictatorships that dominated Latin
America during the 70s and 8s hold Henry
Kissinger at least partially responsible
for the gross human rights violations
that occurred either through Omission or
direct consent and in the words of some
of Kissinger's staunchest adversaries
his death means that he
could make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer